[Musique]
ah oui on est d'accord pas jetter les
déchet dans la nature dans le sac n
respect pas en
fait mchets
etés la FL c'est notre bule d'oxygène la
nature du
coup faut
[Musique]
Pr la nature est trop belle pour la
saccagée préservonsla voilà on va pas
laisser traîner du plastique des
emballages dans la nature surtout quand
on est passé au au jardin Mascarin où on
voit bien que il y a des espèces qui
sont
endémique si j'ai bien retenu la leçon
et qu'il faut préserver cet écosystème
sinon il disparaîtra et il reviendra
jamais j'aiécris l'emprunter sans sans
l'emprunter c'est dire on va prendre le
sentier on va profiter mais on va éviter
de laisser nos trac on a beaucoup de
chance ici on a une nature magnifique
magnifique alors faut vraiment la
préserver faire attention moi je trouve
que on court mais qu'on trouve plein de
déchets partout dans les
sentiers je donner l'exemple parce que
c'est vrai que si attend tous que ce
soit l'utre qui qui le fasse ben on
avancera pas et donc c'est pour ça que
notre nature est belle protégeonsla
ramassons no déchets parce que on a
regardé on a fait un constat cette année
c'est quand même triste il y a eu
beaucoup beaucoup de déchets dans le
voilà
éduqué donc c'est à nous pseudo adulte
qui sommes censés être éduqués déjà
n'est-ce pas de transmettre aux jeunes
une bonne éducation je pense que c'est
une bonne voix on est une bonne
génération qui monte là c'est bien il
faut protéger la nature et ne rien
jouter propre comme au premier jour B
j'évit le faire du
trail parce que lundi j'aimerais pas
être à la place des senti
voilà n RAM bien déchet aussi et puis
nous attentioni
ou mais il est bénéfique je te jure la
nature ça tu CIS qu'on arrive à ça
comment forcment copain avec la
[Musique]
nature